with some of the people that make
minutes with this is a hundredth episode
of the series and we wanted to do
something a little bit different we
wanted to take the opportunity to go
back into some of our favorite moments
from across the series as a whole and
also respond to some of the frequently
asked questions from you the viewers
thank you very much for watching
it's because of you that we can continue
to make this series and for anyone
that's slightly disappointed hoping it
was interesting people speaking this
week don't worry there'll be a regular
episode dropping on sunday at 4 pm uk
time as usual
[Music]
right so this is probably uh the most
received question that we get uh across
any platform but what's your favorite
episode
um
i don't mind my favorite episode is
sweet anita the uh woman with tourette's
syndrome brilliant she was articulate
and told her story so so well and we
brought her back to another video but
did really well as well so i think she's
my favorite because she was emotional
and also kind of funny and entertaining
and a good episode to watch a lot of
people who have tourettes tend to report
that they have fewer ticks or none
during sex but the thing about that is
that's because it engages your focus so
that only applies to good sex um which
is really [ __ ] brutal because i've
never hurt a guy's ego more than simply
going
during an intimate moment i think when
that video went out on youtube actually
it was our fastest video ever to hit a
million yeah i think so yeah um i loved
the crime scene cleaner
um i think i saw it before you love
gross things you love gross things thank
you
no i saw it before i even joined and i
was i just thought it was an amazing
topic and i've never heard about it i
really loved it and um and then i came
here to work and worked on the series i
probably cleaned up close to three or
four hundred different scenes where
people have disemboweled themselves put
a knife in their stomach and and kept
themselves open while they're alive
even one gentleman
decided to take some scissors and cut
his intestines while he'd done it and
throw them in the bath i thought i was
going to be sick on that one really yeah
behind the camera yeah he was getting
into the details i could handle this and
halfway through it i just felt really
light-headed
and i've never had that behind camera
before but i just don't you can't like
stop a guy it did flow and just go i'm
gonna go be sick from what you've said
it's one of the great like stories of
the show it's like being behind being
behind the cameras and then turning
around and seeing gym or someone there
it's going
and pulling your face it's like reacting
alive i think that was one of the few
episodes we cut quite a few bits out
because we just so gross too gross yeah
that was one of the ones we were worried
about on facebook wasn't it yeah how
would i remember we had to just cut
around it basically
i mean he's describing it isn't it so
it's like technically okay but
um yeah it wasn't too gross visually was
it no thankfully i thought the from the
ones which
women people i've interviewed um i
really liked ruby which was the first
marriage episode i think she was
brilliant she was an amazing speaker she
was story was just it was shocking but
what was and like it really touched me
but what was interesting that remember
jim she was telling us
oh guys i'm sorry you have to listen to
this like are you okay she was asking us
while she's telling us this story about
like
the like abuse she went through and it
was just
yeah yeah she's apologizing to us yeah
yeah yeah yeah and she was like she was
so cheerful and laughing though she went
through some terrible things and it was
a very long interview but then it was an
amazing episode and um really feel proud
for covering topics like that as well i
knew i knew who was going to rape me and
that's what happened and it became like
every single day and that was very tough
to kind of
go through
um he was he looked young he did look
young but it was after the marriage that
i knew that he was twice my age so i was
15 he was 30.
going through the rape every single day
like i said i had to disconnect myself i
had to just
where i took myself and this is very
personal it's like i took myself to the
beach in my head i was on a beach
because that i grew up next to a beach i
love being by the sea
and
that's my that's my zen place
and i used to take myself there my brain
said whatever's happening to my body is
happening
but my brain would be elsewhere
and that's how i kept myself alive but
when after he's done
i remember going to the bathroom and
just sitting under the shower for like
an hour and just cleaning my trying to
clean every single part of me off
what about you jim you've probably
worked on more episodes than anyone else
being the op
i think it's one of the first ones we
ever filmed i think it's because i was
like we weren't
we're not that we're desensitized but
having worked on so many now i feel like
you can
handle certain subjects a little bit
more than we could at the start and the
first one we did
uh with the guy who had uh schizophrenia
oh yeah johnny benjamin um
his was like he walked in and he he
looked like
one of my mates you know it could have
been mason for years and he sat down
um and this went through his story and
he was so raw and emotional and never
even heard about those certain
conditions for schizophrenia and
uh i i was crying yeah we don't know if
you i looked at danny as well it was
just like yeah just like came out but it
was just the most yeah emotional
interview i think i've ever watched
i just
it was yeah it was a massive shock
because
i mean schizophrenia everything i
thought about schizophrenia was
i guess like from the media and that was
all
people with schizophrenia were dangerous
and violent and um
i just i couldn't i really couldn't take
it in for a long time this diagnosis it
took me years to
deal with it to be honest because uh
i kind of thought my life was over as
soon as i got that diagnosis
george margot um i think my favorite
episode has to be
how i escaped north korea twice i just
thought the the things that that woman
went through
you couldn't even make it up like it's
on another level isn't it and and the
fact that at the very end she gets
spoiler alert gets uh reunited with the
sun is just like it's like a it's like a
movie isn't it if ever there was never
so there should be a movie one
hours i paint and then i burst my child
but i'm very happy
it's my family
so when my child hungry days is a
chinese man really drunk
and he came to home and he took he told
me that
i wanted to sword my child
i just
stand up and i holding the knife
if you touched my son i kill you um erin
um i was also going to say ruby but just
like i think as a female like watching
that story and listening to her and also
like interacting with her and everything
that she's been through
um
it was really moving like personally and
then
yeah i think the thing about this show
is like meeting the the range of people
you get to interact with on a daily
basis but ruby like was telling the most
horrific thing but then yeah she was
like apologizing to all of us for for
her story and being like are you guys
okay and i just found that like super
powerful and also like coming to work at
loud bible and seeing that how this
platform is like used for
like stories like this of like the
female experience is yeah pretty special
cancer
well are you luke
um
come on you've talked to every single
person we've cast
um i'd have to say
um
jono lancaster
um
i'd been trying to
line something up with him for a while
yeah and um yeah finally you know the
perfect series to you know get him on
board with my adoption report
says
that
jonathan lancaster was born on the 31st
of the 10th 1984.
both parents were horrified by the
child's appearance
both parents felt no maternal bond
and both parents left the hospital 36
hours later leaving the child behind
and
and and those words
you know it's something
this was obviously stuck with me
and um you know when i had
yeah angrier periods in my life but you
know i i focused on those words
a lot and and they cut deep amazing
story
a really inspirational guy
and yeah literally when um
when i called him and offered him you
know the opportunity to come on and talk
about his experiences
he didn't hesitate in getting on board
uh and because the sort of the man he is
uh he wants to sort of put a positive
message out there and um it was great to
give him you know our platform to do so
um i think mine in the end might be the
sniper episode we did when you meet him
he's such an amazing person and you
watch him and you think he's his massive
tough guy and sort of growing up you
look at people like that and think
that's what i want to look like
basically
and then
he can talk you through why he's ended
up with his condition
and it was amazing to put that video out
and see people the viewers go on that
journey and
you'd be worried about comments being
unkind or about like oh if you can't
handle it don't go in the army or things
like that but they weren't really
because because of the way he told the
story and because of who he was as a
person you sort of saw that they
i don't know they bought into the fact
that it's a condition that clearly can
happen to anybody
i think there was a massive positive
response from them and he was really
pleased with the piece and we brought
him back up yeah we got him we got a
charity thing for him didn't we and the
audience raised 10 thousand pounds i
think it was for his um survival school
you know we was using the machine guns
on both sides because soon as they hear
a sniper shot
they all run off
so i told the machine guns to start
firing the gym piece to start firing and
it masks our shots
and they came from
north they came from the south they came
from the east they came from the west
they came from
everywhere and
we got absolutely
i'm gonna say we got absolutely smashed
we thought we were gonna go over run
so i phoned tanya
i get a bit upset you know sorry
um
i phoned her and she answered
and um
and i said to i love you you know
and she because i know she
she goes what's what noise
and i said that has nothing that's
nothing
i said i'll phone you in the morning i
promise you i'll phone you in the
morning
i just want to hear a voice you know
just want to hear
her voice
but like he's a good example because we
cast him because he was telling really
interesting things about sniping like in
terms of like
things like the fact you've got to be
with a partner and wipe their bum which
is such a silly little thing to say but
then he was that was the kind of easy
way to get people in and then you
actually have this really deep dark like
ptsd story underneath it all which is
which kind of holds all together and
makes it really special
the other one i'll say that i was just
thought was an unbelievable story was
the terrorist turn spy which was more in
the kind of north korean thing it's just
kind of one of those titles that you
think oh imagine we got something like
that and
i think you talked to him and he was
flying him in really late but he was
flying like two hours after this year he
wasn't allowed
to work perfect yeah it just clicked
into place and he came in did the whole
thing one takes brilliant it was intense
it was intense 45 minutes to fit all
that in a 45-minute interview
you know one thing you should know about
espionage as well as bomb-making
the first mistake is your last mistake
you're not going to live to make another
mistake and therefore you have to be
absolutely careful you know one wrong
word
you know and you are
a head shorter and six feet under let's
move on to the next question
uh which episode affected you the most
i was editing it i wasn't interviewing
you did you interview uh child sacrifice
i did yeah the woman chose sacrifice
activists so um her story was incredible
i i was i was only editing it but i i
cried over it many times and
i was just moved by her i was just moved
by the story i was it was it was
unbelievable like the the everything
about it the fact that this happens and
i didn't know about that the fact that
there are women who just go there and
just sacrifice their life to do that
um it was a yeah it was it was something
there was a witch doctor who had laid
this child down
and put herbs all around her body
and was about to cut her
before
the security guard
found her and rescued her and brought
her to this um baby's home where i was
working i think that's the thing is it's
a real privilege doing this because like
it's people sharing with you like often
the worst moment of their life which is
like
really tough them to do and like they're
reliving experience but they want to do
it because they've got a message at the
end of it usually what steps affected
you the most ben
um well i to be honest um
the one that affected me most in how i
in
would probably be
kevs the guy with terminal cancer from
the first series
and that took about two months before
the fateful day when i sat in front of a
urologist at the hospital and they
looked at me and said i'm sorry
but
you might probably only live for two
years you know he said don't think ten
if you're lucky you might live three to
four so the reason for that is he had
prostate cancer
and i think like the thing that really
struck me is it's
quite an embarrassing illness like it's
the sort of thing that men don't really
want to talk about and think about
and um he was describing
the symptoms of it and one of those was
getting up during the night loads to
have a pee
and
that's what i do so i basically went to
the doctor after that and got a checkup
and you know it was all fine um but
the reason it affected me is because
what he said is i should have got a
checkup earlier something i knew
something was wrong i had these symptoms
i should have got a checkup earlier and
if i had it could have been different
and it made me think about health and it
made me think about the things you're
embarrassed to talk about and the things
that you don't want to but the fact that
really if there is something going on
you should confront it straight away
um
they do a big push on it at the moment
i've heard adverts on the on the radio
any mail over 50 go and get it checked
out and all that kind of thing but it
just made me think about like
if something
don't ignore stuff is basically how i
thought about it what about you george
uh the episode that affected me the most
i think the good thing about minutes
with and you probably all agree is that
they kind of make you grateful for the
situation that you've got and like the
episode that stood out to me the most in
that regard was probably the one with
thunder the guy who stowed away on the
plane from south africa because the
plane just left without
any problem in the flood like sweetheart
to come and stop the plane or maybe you
were being spot maybe climbing over to
the plane no nothing did happen
when i mean there i can see some houses
i can see some cars down there because
when it goes up you have to go like this
so when it goes up it gives you a big
view you can see
you can see all the places down there
i remember just there all the time
college decision when we made it i said
some years after it passed out with
oxygen he's trying to escape her life in
south africa that is awful and the
lengths that he would go through to
escape such a life is just
you wouldn't even think about it
yourself
um and that obviously you know just
makes you grateful for that you have a
bad day at work you think you know it
can never be that bad yeah um and then
the second half of it the fact that just
a random stranger obviously went up to
him and is now helping him and i think
at the end of the episode he ends up
getting him accommodation to live in and
he's got all these new things he was
went from living on the street to having
his own house just because of the
kindness of a random person on the
street um yeah i thought that was just
like a nice reminder that people aren't
always the worst it's like a perfect
love bible story like like an everyday
hero helping out somebody has a need
it's like just so loud bible is it yeah
i want the god to look after you after
this guy as well because this guy is
decent and he's please he do it for me
to his heart you know he did it from his
heart you can see guys like this one
they need to be trusted from the eyes of
their god because they are do it with
with their heart they don't do it with
the
uh doji you know they don't play dodgy
thing yeah
um
come on what's your uh the one that
impacted you the most um
i think meeting alex lewis i think that
episode um because it's that thing about
like someone coming in with just like
an unbelievable life story and a tragic
set of circumstances and the way they
like carry themselves and present
themselves and have like turned their
tragedy into a really like positive
situation
um i think i felt very like moved by
meeting him and hearing his story
making affordable wheelchairs for um
ethiopians with various disabilities
predominantly through polio but a lot
through
war
all of this work is going to help
tons of people
you know the the prosthetics have
already helped
i think we raised 700 000 pounds at the
back end of the sort of start of last
year
so every child in the uk under 10 with
limb difference gets a free arm
for everything that's been
put into me the millions of pounds in
healthcare
the constant healthcare
the least i can do is to
continue working
and trying to make it
better for others
so really my
my my working life my career started
about eight years ago
it wasn't
when i was 33 certainly not i didn't do
enough with my
my education
the life i had
i didn't make the most of it and i
regret that massively what a um best
best talker best most articulate the
best talk we've had got to be jamie
jamie tommy yeah yeah yeah
i've got i've got to hold on i've got to
get a grip here and i've got to do
exactly that so i kept my left hand on
the the flight control stick and my
right hand on the throttle and i
carefully just knocked off that power on
the throttle to try to reduce air speed
and i needed to reduce that
significantly in order to get myself to
a a relatively safe speed approaching
the active runway all the time i'm
watching the altimeter spin down so
through
900 feet 800 feet 700 feet 600 feet and
i've got that left hand on control right
hand on the throttle
when i'm trying to breathe and i'm
trying to think through it
and i'm just trying to really calm it
all down as much as possible uh yeah he
was really good i i think sweden either
i think sweden in terms of like um she
was really good at conveying something
very very complex in a very simple way
to the audience and i think she did so
much for the threats in that video
not david mcmillan
david macmillan is my favorite his voice
is just i wish he narrated my life in my
head he was like a walking podcast yeah
he's amazing like he's uh i think that's
actually i don't know if it's
interesting for anyone but um with his
interview i i just found it so
interesting that
i meant to cut it into two episodes and
i think
they've done really well they've both i
think
close to a million maybe over a million
already he was great and he's just a
story like you just sit down just listen
to it and it's amazing
even as it was i had to persuade him to
be quiet on the night
i had to be quite cruel to him in a way
to frighten him
because when he started moaning a bit
loudly at the
grief of being caught with people
escaping i had to lean down next to him
and i got close to his ear
i said mirage
believe me
when i tell you the only reason the only
reason i don't kill you immediately
is that it would upset
my friends in the cell
but it won't upset me and i will if you
make another sound what the whichever
the weirdest title we don't remember the
titles we rejected one that we're almost
did i can't remember just thinking back
to like it's a bionic penis
bionic pain it sounds like it's going to
be like this robocop terminator penis
yeah um that's not but it was something
it was a blow up penis yeah isn't it
yeah and also it's not he was lovely yes
if anything it's an educational piece
yeah but it does you there's no way you
could package it without it seeming like
you're trying to be click baiter yeah
yeah yeah
he obviously looked at my arm and said
to me we can make you about this says
the princess i was like whatever
i could have said to my 10 inch one
and i guess that's what you've got to do
on facebook a little bit more not be
click dated but you've got to try and
draw people in because they're just
scrolling down their timeline on the
phone and you've got to grab their
attention immediately so yeah phrase
like bionic penis is obviously going to
do that whereas on youtube you know i
think people now they wait for the
episodes to come out and they know what
to expect whereas on facebook you've got
to grab people's attention a bit more so
that's why doing the clips with the
titles at the top um and sort of picking
out the right keywords was a big step
for us in that
yeah okay next quest uh next
man
were you laughing at me something in my
world
sounds like me
right
next question which episode has received
the most views
i'll look and take this one there yeah
go on luke
um i was looking the other day it is
plane crash survivor is it not it's
jono john
how are you talking though were you
talking on youtube it depends on the
platform i think on youtube the biggest
is craig the sniper yes i think it's
close putting creating
showing myself up here
i mean look luke starts every morning
with checking the numbers
before you get before you have coffee
yes it's no yours is second because i
think on youtube it's craig and it's
playing crash then speed of hal hunter
isn't it mike
yeah three three big hitters
across facebook as well
i'm not sure i think john is john or not
john
john john's the biggest one on facebook
yeah definitely i think we put three
clips and last time i checked i think
one of those had 22 million views yeah
yeah yeah the clip that has i was
abandoned by my parents because of my
fears yeah it's like that's the highest
thing we've ever had for you on minutes
with definitely
are there any episodes you thought
deserved more views than they got
um yes
not a lot of them yeah all of them yeah
i would love all old movie more uh no i
don't know
um i think from the recent ones the down
syndrome actor i thought deserved more
views and he actually did get more views
on all other platforms except it takes
time on youtube
did big numbers big numbers he did i
think good numbers on
facebook as well yeah yeah
um that's just the first one that come
comes to my head because i was really
passionate about making it and i think
it's really important to
and when i was actually when i was
preparing for it um
i found it really weird that i didn't
find really any interviews on youtube
with the
people with down syndrome like sit down
like one-on-one interviews and um that
was another reason to do it would you
say that there is something you
dislike about the acting world
uh
being the lady bombs
doesn't hate me at most
um
because i really do want to get rid of
light
labels
but um
by saying
yes we can
do things i'm going to say something
pretty different which i i've got a
ghost hunters didn't do better
it was like it was like so good it was
so serious it was so stupid it was not
stupid it was so silly because like we
got them to do like a test of the office
with their ghosts in the office and like
i was terrified me and jim don't forget
we don't believe in ghosts i think it's
fair
but they said it darn and then when they
start saying like
any spirits in the room and if that
thing had beat we'd lean out of there
we were trying to make it beef and stuff
we were trying but it would it was so it
was so much fun to do and like we were
having good fun with it and they were
really nice people
so if there's any spirits here in this
room with us now
we ask that you please approach lorraine
come towards the doll
and come and touch her
come towards her and touch her she'll
light up and make a sound
my uh my episode that i thought would
have performed better was from that
first series as well and it was a
stuntman so the stunt coordinator was
going to fire the air ram so it had a
lead with the button going to him offset
when he does fire the button i'm
virtually in line with the ground so he
fires the air ram which fires me
straight onto the back of my neck and
literally i'm lying on the floor and i
can't feel my legs and this went on for
about two minutes it's the worst feeling
in the world you know i thought i was
paralyzed could not feel my legs at all
thought i'd broken my neck he was
brilliant and he
yeah gladiator star wars yeah bond he'd
been in they've been in all these
brilliant things throughout the window
by stallone he got thrown out of the
window by sloan and judge dredd yeah um
um and i was sure that just this list of
films would draw people in to be like oh
i'd be interested in that
it didn't do badly and it was a good
episode but uh that was one where i
really thought it would go through the
roof yeah i was surprised
do you read the comments oh yes
each one of
them i make note of all the bad ones and
i put them in my black book
she will find you
we have to hold mariana back from
replying
i create different accounts
wasn't it someone's idea in the comments
for us all to do this it was yes um i'm
going to post it on the screen over
danny's face
it was uh it was somebody posted that
they'd be interested in the kind of
behind the scenes thing and like seeing
the crew i think they actually said
something about
marriott wondering what might happen
yeah which i'm a bit annoyed about
because i did like 50 episodes and no
one asked to see what i look like
you know how an annoying irishman is
going to look like
yeah who's that idiot in the background
or whatever it is i've only done a few
so i've sort of escaped the uh the ira i
think i did i think i did one of the
ones i did and i think there was a
comment saying last week's interview was
better well oh really well no
it was mariana not yet
there was a lot of comments saying that
i sound like like a dude so
i'm like a dude like a dude yeah
i have quite a long voice they're all
they're also i've seen losers trying to
guess where you're from yeah i'm not
going to tell anyone i think you could
guess in the comment section yeah and
whoever guesses gets closest to the city
gets it right gets uh gets pinned
comment i don't know whatever i
genuinely think the comments are really
interesting i read them all it's like
it's that thing where the outlier like
if there's one saying
stupid stuff or like that they hate this
person or whatever just ignore those
because they're not useful but there's
quite a lot of interesting
comments about how to improve the series
that you can you know what people want
to see and also and i'll take the hit on
this one i fought against the interview
being mic'd up for ages because we did
it right right at the beginning and it
felt like because minutes width is a
really stripped back show where it feels
like you can sort of see the set it felt
like the interviewer's voice came over i
don't we just hadn't done it properly in
the edit but it felt like it'd been
overlaid afterwards and it sort of took
you out of the moment and then it was
just
endless comments about mike the
interviewer might be interviewing you
there's like a monthly basis going we
should make the interview yeah we go no
i don't like it and then we we did it
once and the first comment was like
thank god you finally might
which was probably written by
what about you aaron do you read the
comments
i do read the comments yeah um i mean i
find like social media comments
fascinating on all platforms but the
youtube generous word
person yeah no he's a very kind person
thank you um yeah i do like sunday's
like kind of a cup of tea sit down bit
hungover and watch an episode of minutes
with
and then we do have like a group chat
where all of us kind of discuss the
comments um
well i don't read all the comments on
facebook because there's a lot
and like there's obviously babons like
there is anywhere but i love the ones
that kind of shut down the bad ones and
like you know like oh you need to ignore
people like this like this is amazing
what you're doing like in terms of the
person telling the story not you guys
yeah
you know saying like how amazing it is
that they're telling coming forward and
telling their story like uh the positive
ones like that i think are really great
yeah craig the sniper who talks a lot
had thousands of dms
on on instagram after the after the
video went live but just the comments as
well so he replied to all of them he
applied to every single person um and
they said they were so supportive and so
like
kind to him
but ben also loves all the comments
which which which praises loud bible
form
yeah i got in there all of that yeah
yeah so if you want to get a hug just
just just just say that you really like
saying those things these interviews
we're doing and it really stepped up the
game
i wasn't asking questions actually sorry
um
in terms of the event you mentioned
about comments being not just horrible
but like constructive and giving
feedback has it been anything else where
the comments have said something and
you've been like oh that's actually a
really good idea we'll implement that
there's been titles i think there's a
lot of titles definitely yeah yeah like
people put episode titles in that you go
that's a really brilliant idea so the
guy who uh was in the bay root explosion
he actually was a big fan of the show
and got in touch with us because he
loved the show we've seen every episode
and then came in fatty that was his name
and didn't even that was nice in terms
of like that was the first one where
someone was like i have an amazing story
i really like this show can i please
come on and tell us and it just worked
really well he was a really good
storyteller very good yeah also one
didn't get enough for you so yeah oh
yeah
and i remember unlocking my phone on
what's up was on and i kind of closed
what's up and clicked on the camera
and the second i clicked the film
i saw what i guess
the whole world saw
how did you decide what it looked like
originally
which portrayed that's the best we did
in that phone call from my garden
suppose we were just working through
what the shop was gonna ask did it kind
of grow out of lockdown because it was
an easy show to film because you've got
one contributor it came from like two
cameras given the fact that we've been
doing a fuse here me and ben joined just
started the lab by originals team about
a year before that and we were doing a
few shows which we'd worked on with you
and there were like six episode runs and
then we were like overlocked and we're
just like we should just need to film
something get loads as many as we can
and release it weekly and really commit
to a weekly release right and we have
committed to a weekly release now for
two years the last two years straight so
it was about volume really people when
we film five in a day yeah i remember at
the beginning especially we did five
back to back for four days in a row or
something yeah i was in a bad way after
absolutely exhausting yeah i mean still
we still do quite a lot yeah yeah i was
basically watching i was behind the
studio just watching from a monitor and
i was tired guys
yeah yeah there was the one we did when
18 i think it was a cost for maybe three
days four days yeah that was brutal uh
luke so how do you go about like finding
people for the show obviously you don't
give away your secrets but is it
difficult to find people i mean some of
them have been pretty obscure
um
what which ones would you say are
obscure
well i mean what's been the hardest one
yeah yes yeah let's um
i'm trying to think of one looking one
yeah i know which one it is
i know the one you worked on for ages
paramount
no bobby cummings oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
he was yeah he was pretty tough frank
was sitting in a motor he was my driver
old frank
he went what's going on i said tomorrow
i'll sit at seven o'clock in the morning
go and get kennedy that was my sign off
shotgun it was named after president
kennedy i said i want one chamber one
buckshot filled with rock salt
and the other one with the normal bug
shot you know right yeah i'm not messing
about with these people they're
dangerous so i'm going to shoot them
yeah i'd probably say bobby bobby
cummings um
just
i mean
where do you start
how do you find him um
but uh no
he's actually um why was he so hard to
find was he had no phone or something
what was it what was it that was so hard
to find he's got a
spanish mobile number uh how old is he
oh he's in he's he's in his eighties
i don't think i don't think he uses like
what's up or anything like that
no
he lives in spain right yeah yes yeah
yeah he's based out in spain um
where do you start um but we know we
managed we managed to get all of him um
and um
it's a great help yeah it was a great
yeah before he's a big guy like the
priesthood of hard time tracking him
down luke managed to fight
somewhere in spain so yeah i think it
wasn't tim peake another one like that
where it was like the planets just
aligned at the last minute yeah yeah
with with tim peake it was like we we
tried
getting in contact various ways and in
the end it was just
through instagram i just commented on
one of his
the latest post
um
slid in the dms
and
yeah emailed
called the agency under um
you know messaged on the facebook page
and then it was instagram in the end as
yuri was bringing the spacecraft in for
the the first manual approach
we were just aware that things were not
going right we had another failure
which meant the computer screen went
down so tim and i were effectively blind
and that was the point i realized this
approach is is just not good and yuri um
actually his hands started trembling on
the controllers we should say that looks
it up the lab bible casting page on
instagram um as another way of like
getting people for all of our shows um
so if anyone does have an amazing story
and once they're on minutes with they
can message book on loud by bloodcasting
i think that's what it's called quite
incredible
yes okay guys i think that's it for this
episode um as i said at the beginning
don't worry we promise never to do this
again and there will be a regular
episode on sunday at 4 p.m uk time as
normal uh thanks so much for watching
it's you guys that make us able to
continue this series and on behalf of
all of us thanks very much bye
[Laughter]
that was actually natural
i got onto the left hand
wing
clambering over that door lip and then i
stood onto the wing
and was able to stand on the wing
momentarily i jumped
i would estimate at a height of about 15
1-5 feet